hey this is preshtalwalker
here's a math problem that's stumping
the internet right now
this question was asked to fifth graders
in china
if a ship had 26 sheep and 10 goats
aboard
how old is the ship's captain
this problem has gotten a lot of media
coverage and i even covered it in a
previous video
but we all missed the real story
this problem was actually devised by
french researchers nearly 40 years ago
and it does teach a valuable lesson
about math class
so in this video i'm going to go over
the real story that no media outlet has
covered so far
before i get to that i want to quickly
go over the media coverage and what some
possible answers have been proposed
so this problem really got coverage
around the world
from the south china morning post
from rt
from the bbc
from the washington post and even in
newsweek
the media coverage focused on solving
the problem
the most sensible answer i saw that was
quoted in the bbc comes from one weibo
commenter
who writes
the total weight of 26 sheep and 10 goat
is 7 700 kilograms based on the average
weight of each animal
now i did a little bit of fact checking
you would actually get 7 700 pounds if
you did this search in wolfram alpha but
let's just forget this little nitpick
and go with seven thousand seven hundred
kilograms
so continuing that response
in china if you're driving a ship that
has more than five thousand kilograms of
cargo you need to have possessed a boat
license for at least five years
the minimum age for getting a boat's
license is 23 so the captain is at least
28.
that's a remarkable leap in logic
but if it sounds too crazy for you
keep in mind
that these kinds of deductions are very
common in sherlock holmes stories
take an example from the hound of the
baskervilles
from examining a walking stick of a man
he has never met
sherlock holmes deduces the man is under
30 years old he's a family doctor and
that he owns a
dog so
the official response in china is that
the question was not a mistake it was
actually meant to be open-ended and
encourage critical thinking which is
usually not present in math class
that would be the end of the story
except this problem did not have its
source in china
the real story is the problem was
originally asked by french researchers
in 1979
this problem is nearly 40 years old
i learned about the problems origin from
benjamin dickman who has a phd in
mathematics education from columbia
university
benjamin heard about the problem because
he believes that many people in math
education have heard about this problem
and similar problems and he tweeted
about it and you could check out his
twitter profile
twitter.com
benjamindickman
so from the sources that he tweeted and
sent
we can actually find in 1979 french
researchers asked first and second
graders the following problem
on the boat there are 26 sheep and 10
goats what is the age of the captain
i couldn't believe it when i was seeing
this
this problem
has been asked nearly 40 years ago
in almost exactly the same wording
so what was the point of this exercise
well from reading some of these sources
the researchers had expected that most
students would think the question is
absurd
the correct answer would have to be
there is not enough information
but what they found was shocking
more than three-fourths of students
actually tried to solve the problem by
manipulating the numbers
they said something like okay the age
must be 26 plus 10 which equals 36.
very few students question if the
problem was even
solvable in fact this was not just a
fluke result
the study was replicated on a larger
scale in countries including france
germany and switzerland even by
researchers who thought this was not
even possible they were antagonistic to
this hypothesis that students would just
manipulate numbers and they found the
same thing
jean worchenko emailed me about this
related problem
his blog his math and logic problems
usually simpler than mine and it has
other posts you can visit his blog at
genew.ca
so the related question is the following
there are 125 sheep and 5 dogs in a
flock
how old is the shepherd
well once again
you would expect the correct answer that
there is not enough information to solve
the problem
but researchers found shocking results
again
many students produce answers by
manipulating the numbers in the question
one student reasoned along the following
lines
well 125 plus 5 equals 130 that's too
old of an age and 125 minus 5 equals 120
that's also too old of an age but 125
divided by 5 equals 25 sounds about
right
so the student concluded the shepherd is
25 years old
so what's the lesson in all of this
the so-called chinese test question that
went viral was really a french research
question from nearly 40 years ago
for such an absurd question the correct
answer is that there is not enough
information
and i give credit to the school in china
for asking this question we still need
to improve the critical thinking skills
of students in math class
we still keep thinking that every
problem we get is solvable and it should
be solvable just by manipulating the
numbers we get
we should always think does the question
actually make sense is there enough
information to solve it
so that's the real story to this viral
math question from china
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math you can catch me on my blog
mindyourdecisions if you like this video
you can check out my books which are
linked in the video description
and you can support me on patreon
if you have a suggestion for a puzzle or
a math topic you can email me at presh
mindyourdecisions.com and you can also
catch me on social media either at mind
your decisions or at preshtalwalkar